peu
[Musique]
m
montaigne
et
à
ah ah
détails
m
oh
on
bonjour
on va travailler d'abord d'accord vous a
préparé de l exercice
[Musique]
les corrections place avec nous
prescrivent l'oxygène
mais comparé à début mai
allez sur la sal alosi à l'aider
allez je dis à mes frères on est prêts
attention va partir cette fois aussi
on fait des grandes mais voilà quelle
pêche même dynamique allez on va
s'arrêter à zaïnab sur la respiration
place pie xii
[Musique]
ah oui j'adore ça mais à chaud les
chenilles les cuisses les hanches
thales qui suit derrière ça quart
d'heure human ce panneau latéral fait
d'accord et avec le sourire
l abattoir sur place l'an passé quand on
avance vous chez vous c'est bien du
surplace la télévision au bowling
pourquoi pas aller à l'élagage et tout
est possible avec nous au sérieux
et
[Musique]
inspiré
joyeux et les voilà ça mais comme un
échauffement 1
le plongeon d'hier avec la job
c'est lui
il atteint
inspiré à sa place un gorille alors oui
ce [ __ ] du bien derrière nous à
l'aller les jaunes bien faire mais bien
un prénom si c'est lui
m
a changé
attention ça l'a suivie dans une seconde
d'avancé
attention
non
[Musique]
qu'ils abusent les genoux sur le côté
l'étal au sol comme toujours et 5 et 6
et on enchaîne deux comme un ressort à
les monter la taille on continue les
changements
[Musique]
elle a changé avec l'état nomme idahc
pour les fesses taper vos talents encore
[Musique]
m
à
les bois
ah ah
[Musique]
on attendait les jambes lourdes et le
but est signé debuchy
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
oui jusqu'au bout 6 et 7 et 8 restés
pliés rentrée les phases corriger la
position russe orval prochaine on en
cherche des as mais c'est bien son buste
on tend la pointe des pieds on t'en sais
je
[Musique]
saleh
j'ai pas vu
là
[Musique]
m
non
dole
j'attendais d'eux
à
reste
espérez-vous vers le prêt à langer vous
chez les gens a relevé la tête face à ça
fait pas bon et et pavot
c
allez
ça colle pas les faits
aux attaques de chaque côté
ça
fait
[Musique]
changer
grande est atteint m
m
jottras
la santé sont pas
non
le haut
[Musique]
alors
je sais pas
oui
[Musique]
c'est le dos ça va
paillé l'a fait ailleurs et usm et ont
changé la mort
mon pierre
[Musique]
m
quant aux tenues
j'étais jeune
de là
[Musique]
non
allez allez allez allez allez allez
allez jusqu'au bout pas d'abandon ne
s'arrête pas en continu a bien tendu et
6 2
[Musique]
on change
c'est noté
[Musique]
aurel
alors le beurre
[Musique]
dans ce sens
blagueur
réflexe
[Musique]
n'est pas
oui
[Musique]
la taille
lavallée
oui
[Musique]
6 7 aux rastas la fonction dont quand tu
sais vous pointez bien vos pièces que
les genoux sont tendus les deux sens tu
es là les deux évidemment lâchait
arrondi cendo souffler et de vous mettez
la musique bien fort nous aussi ce qu
avec le vent c'était 6,7 alors là c'est
pas difficile au sein d'un coup ses
genoux sur le côté et ouvrir l'eau les
chambres et 8 ont changé
[Musique]
eh ouais
sans exagération et 5 et 6
7 et 8 ont changé
[Musique]
merci
passé
[Musique]
le piston d'un fort loin derrière
regardez les plans ont mis l'émetteur
placez place oui l2
détroit auprès jeunes ou encore ouvre
les pieds passés entre les 5 et 6 allers
et six sacs attention on change de pied
et ans et 5 et 6 et 7 et 8 on change pli
ouvrez les genoux ballon au sol en
compte à jean jaurès de phase ii phase
5b 6b vous sonne et 8 changer de pied
mais le principal mais on garde toujours
les anges de phase 6
cette tension ça changeait et deux et
trois rendez-vous est tiré vers le haut
si
7-8 ont changé et 3 et 4 qui l'a leurs
parents chez en avant et 7 et 8
maintenant
si c'est pas tomber
bien posé au sol 6 les possibilités
des gars qu'on courait
m
et toi
on chante
[Musique]
les templiers
d'accord c'est ça ma légion
quand les pages oui
[Musique]
reste
c'est bien
6 7 8 on reste la pause véronique vous
blesser avec les ans
seulement là pied travail là elle est en
charge
[Musique]
il
c
[Musique]
jean
en pologne
en données corrigées vous là quand on a
une position l'art est rentré au pays il
reste debout à bobigny la tête avec
véronique c'est pas salé des cons
restait deux gouttes enfin or alors oui
que les paroles du porte-parole
[Musique]
passer la main
une récré vrai crève bâtard être avec
nous mettons charge
non
allez vous avec nous tafoid
[Musique]
m
là
à
[Musique]
outre les jambes le député paul g
les épaules
c'est
[Musique]
encore
mon sens
[Musique]
myv
voilà
[Musique]
ap
là
[Musique]
oh
abba
là
[Musique]
m
pour
[Musique]
bada
voilà un espace un espace facile donc on
va pas vous l'expliquer il est très
géométrique
voilà on vous l'expliquent pas mais on
vous le montre une fois et ensuite vous
le prenez en arche avec nous d'accord
allez on envoie la musique
[Musique]
oui
oh
pourquoi
on
[Musique]
ok
elle
m
[Musique]
une
e
non
[Musique]
attendu
ou pas
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
non
je
[Musique]
allez
beaucoup
[Musique]
le monde
e
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
et bien notre surprise promis c'est
gilbert montagné et on va faire notre
vie avec le début de match
ouais
c'est là
on va toucher derrière
on a brûlé
elle se vit
comme les i
tu as aimé
sympa
les plaies
d
[Musique]
la quitter
c mu mais beaucoup
[Musique]
ce voeu
m
on peut découvrir
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
j'en ai maintenant
oh
sur place
je suis
[Musique]
on fait tout nous
oh
à
[Musique]
m
toujours plus haut
à voir
[Musique]
l'opinion
oh
[Musique]
bah
et
[Musique]
quelle page
accor
la merveille cette chanson fait de
relaxation avec la respire très fort
et qui est un petit peu tes jambes voilà
[Musique]
fou
la salmonelle
[Musique]
vous le faites avec nous
reste droit au monde devant
baa
dans le monde
on le lâche de moi c'est l'autre
ouah
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
m
pour
les sens contraire
alors vas-y toi
il y a
très loin
recommencer
avec un soin de soi
ça
respirez la chine et l'autre bras
[Musique]
les ondes et bien
bien
chaque
les
des sanglots
on n'est pas allé
mais où
[Musique]
à
je t'invite à quoi de tes lumières
il y en a pas
bien sûr mois encore
[Musique]
et
m
regardez gilbert gress
voix
[Musique]
voilà
dans la communication entre les mains de
chantier ce qui ce passe de
[Musique]
or les bras
à
des soins
reste je vais poursuivre car le plein de
choses à se dire
je pense oui moi je voulais dire quand
même d'abord que vraiment ça me fait
très très plaisir d'être parmi vous
parce que quand j'ai l'occasion d'être
la maison dimanche quand je regarde un
peu ça et puis j'aime bien parce que
tout ça en stimulant et je lisais que je
me suis bien faire un tour dans voilà
important parce que ça te dire aussi
c'est qu'on adopte des chansons et
d'ailleurs à l'école de danse on les
passe tous les jours
oui dans notre émission aussi et quand
on nous a dit qu'ils allaient venir
jouer les données d'un pronom pour le
moins de traces et partager ce que tu
fais comme succès les concerts que tu
donnes à droite et à gauche et tu es
toujours pourquoi quand on entend à la
radio qu'on peut la télévision souriant
oui c'est vrai je pense que je partage
une ligne philosophique je les partage
et je pense que c'est très important de
voir le positif des choses l'aérobic
pour moi le tonique
en général c'est très positif tout ça
c'est en fait de faire sortir le trop
plein d'énergie ou le mauvais côté
l'énergie comprend surtout en habitant
dans les villes nos pauvres citadins
je pense que c'est un train de faire
sortir tout ça est alors surtout quand
on peut faire
surtout cela en rythme en tempo puisque
le thème imposé très important à
l'antenne j'en ai un peu on a tous un
tempo différente puisque on a tous des
battements de coeur qui sont quand même
différent donc moi je pense qu'on a
vraiment tous notre de points nous
personnes seulement une chose fabuleuse
c'est que tu es un cas rare tu es un
poète dynamique tout était d énergie
tullett eu les hutus métro fut tué quand
tu vois genre gendarmes je pense que mon
mode de vision était complètement basé
sur l'énergie en fait puisque ma vision
a laissé la vision de l'esprit donc ça
se passe tout à l'intérieur alors je
présume que quand on veut quand on veut
utiliser cette énergie d'un dans un
autre dans un orphelinat sur la sens
bien positif on peut tous le faire c'est
très important donc déjà pour beaucoup
de courage et de volonté ce que tu as on
veut c'est une grande envie quand je dis
on reste un peu sur ma joie de vivre un
besoin de remuer
we do ré revenus d'ailleurs fait le dieu
qui attend les adversaires dax en faire
mention annonce l'accord swing oui je
pense que exactement tu es tu as dit le
mot juge penser c'est un swing swing
corporelle
moi c'est ce que c'est ce qui me plaît
avait avec avec
ce que ce que nous voyons c'est que ça
rejoint le mouvement physique et puis
aussi et puis aussi le mental que bien
important l'expression en fait
l'expression
en tout cas on est folle de joie de que
tu es participer parce qu'on s'est dit
peut-être qu'il va vouloir simplement
venir parler avec nous et quand on nous
a dit mais non il veut faire le job et
puis tu étais minutes et ça sachant que
tu aurais tu es tout le court arthur
ashe on prend rendez vous allez écrire
alors qu est qu il a pris rendez-vous et
nous on prend rendez vous avec vous la
semaine prochaine
rester fidèle au revoir merci
[Musique]